ja und es geht nicht um nicht mehr und
nicht weniger als um das
aufstiegsversprechen in unserer
gesellschaft zu erneuern das große
problem das wir haben ist dass wir eine
große abhängigkeit haben zwischen
bildungserfolg und herkunft der kinder
und das müssen wir durchbrechen wenn wir
wollen das hat hier nicht vererbt wird
dass wir keine generation von
hartz-iv-familien erzeugen da müssen wir
schauen dass nicht der goldenen löffel
im mund entscheidend ist sondern die
schätze im kopf für das was ein mensch
erreichen kann und seines glückes
schmied zu sein und das ist das große
problem das wir haben und wenn ich mir
meine heimatstadt berlin anschaue da ist
die abhängigkeit von herkunft und
bildungserfolg extrem maßgebend und das
müssen wir durchbrechen und zwar sehr
schnell wenn wir nicht große teile der
bevölkerung für immer in eine bestimmte
richtung schieben wollen und der
bildungsarmut ist auch ein großes
problem was wir haben und das müssen wir
durchbrechen da geht es um frühkindliche
bildung die wir deutlich verstärken
müssen wir müssen die kinder früh dahin
bringen dass sie wenn sie in die schule
kommen auch der schule folgen können wir
haben viele viele kinder die in die
schule kommen müssen nicht in der lage
sind im unterricht zu folgen das muss
man sich einmal vorstellen werden
bildungsverlierer produziert von einem
system und wir schaffen es nicht diese
aufzufangen und ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass wir bildung als
aufstiegs chance brauchen wir wissen
alle wir haben einen fachkräftemangel in
deutschland die köpfe unserer menschen
sind unsere ressourcen in diesem land
die beine brechen durch durch eine
bessere bildung wir müssen tatsächlich
viel früher anfangen mit bildung und wir
haben die idee entwickelt in berlin zu
sagen wir hätten gerne wieder stärkere
vorschulische arbeit in den
kindertagesstätten und zwar mit einer
pflicht des besuchs im letzten kita-jahr
das tatsächlich jedes kind einmal in der
kita war
und dann auch dort auf die schule
vorbereitet wird und wenn nicht dann
noch nicht so weit bin dass sich der
schule noch nicht folgen kann ja weil
die sprachliche defizit habe vielleicht
auch
noch nicht so weit bin als individuum
das haben wir immer wieder dass kinder
auch jetzt schon zurückgestellt werden
in den kindertagesstätten da ist dann
auch dieses jahr noch mal wiederholen
damit kinder sobald sie die schule
erreichen in der lage sein ansatz zu
probieren den eltern schon direkt zu
helfen also wir haben ja gerade zum
beispiel 500.000 freie jobs fast in
diesem und dass man vielleicht probiert
mehr menschen aus hartz 4 andy jobs zu
finden das sie selber versorgen können
und für eine bessere absolut aber hier
geht es
tatsächlich gar nicht um das ökonomische
probleme der eltern unbedingt sondern es
geht darum den bildungserfolg der kinder
davon abzukoppeln ja also natürlich
müssen wir gucken dass so viele menschen
wie möglich in arbeit kommen aber für
mich ist wichtig dass diese kinder alle
chancen haben den offen stehen und dass
sie nach ihrem leistungsvermögen den
besten abschluss hinbekommen ja das muss
nicht immer das aber man kann nur sagen
armen nur weil im großen respekt herr
fresdorf und ich würde das gar nicht ich
würde das jetzt drei mal respekt ich mag
es aber wirklich total wichtiges thema
ist aber wir diskutieren darüber seit 30
jahren seit seit ich meine zeit willy
brandt der hat das gemacht als rot grün
hatte aber als ganztagsschulen programm
aufgesetzt 16 jahre lang ist nichts
passiert unter der großen koalition
leider auch nicht nur dass schwarz gelb
in dieser richtung das thema kauen wir
sie können aber scheint es möglich wenn
sagen einsatz funktioniert sie ihre
partei stellt doch die
bildungsministerin die den namen kennt
kein mensch ich habe von dir auch nichts
gelesen nichts gehört an initiativen
und ich hab ich denke schon sie haben da
einiges schon gelegenheit das da das da
was passiert ich weiß das ist
ländersache aber es gab mal eine zeit da
gab es impulse wir werden jetzt heute
einfach mit dem appell schließen schade
[Gelächter]
da haben sie mich auf meiner seite
halten